and today I'm going to talk about
external tools in canvas since we
started using canvas we've been
experimenting with a lot of external
tools and external tools are the tools
that are available through canvas so it
could be any other tool or developed by
our develop developers at the school
that we access them through canvas so
most of these integrations are available
on to the course navigation and I'm
going to show some examples some of the
integrations that when you access to
them they are on the Left navigation bar
so you can access through that some of
them are available through assignments
so if you're using a specific tool
external tool you can only access them
to assignments and some of the examples
are here like mobile a bankful ticket
some of them are available through
module so in order to use those tools
you have to use modules and also HTML
editors that we are using right now work
wire and I'm going to in turn you know
show that and they also experimented by
integrating these tools within the
sub-account and within courses so we
tried different levels of integrations
also so past and current so far we use
warp wires we name it it shows on the
Left navigation bar and we name it
course videos warp wire is our media
platform so instead of connector school
of management is using more plier and
this is how we are accessing work wire
from within canvas so basically I'm just
going to maybe so you can see it here
it's on the Left navigation and when
students or users you know instructors
when they click on it they are accessing
work wire within canvas and it's you
know already integrated they don't have
to go to another platform to use the
platform they just within canvas access
to this platform so go to the next one
and so on syllabus that's another tool
that we developed at School of
Management to have access to our syllabi
on a different platform so I'm going to
show you an example too and hopefully we
will be retiring that too soon because
you're going to go back to the syllabus
available within canvas so if a user
clicks on this on syllabus they have
access to the syllabus that is actually
hosted in another platform called
confluence
so again without living janmas by
clicking on that link they access to it
and they don't have to sign in you don't
have to enter and username or password
roster roster tool was developed by som
developers also we since then retired it
because now University has a really good
photo roster that we can use but before
University had a roster we created our
own with the pictures and with the name
of the students and their emails we are
not using it anymore but that's another
tool that we developed and we've been
using cameras and voicethread again
while integrating canvas we integrated a
lot of tools and one of the tools that
we tried out was voicethread and
voicethread is an online platform for
providing feedback on the media files
and the feedback can be an audio file
video file text and any type of file
that you can share so I'm going to click
on it so you see how we access it but
since then we stopped paying for the
voicethread license so we don't have any
access to it but again voicethread was
available on the Left navigation bar as
well as in assignment so we could create
assignments and have students access
voicethread or we were using it on the
Left navigation bar so our users who
just click on it and go to voicethread
without entering their username and
password so these are the ones that
we've been using and these are tested so
when I say tested I mean we hear about
these tools and we read about them and
investigate and we implemented in our
sometimes accountable sometimes there's
the sandbox a course level I try to do
it mostly at the course level these are
some of the ones that we tested and we
decided that it's not ready yet it's not
working as much as we want them to be
working there are some issues with them
so we are still either trying to decide
or decide not to pursue so one of them
is called Turnitin you're all familiar
with Turnitin it's a plagiarism tool and
we are using it externally so our
faculty and staff members are going to
turn it in and uploading all these
documents so we were thinking it would
be helpful if you provide this access
within canvas
unfortunately the right now you see
error because my test account is expired
we had some issues with it it was 100%
accurate it works better externally as
as another platform rather than within
canvas so we are still trying to decide
if you should just ask our users to use
an external platform or use within
canvas the next one that we are testing
is actually we did already we are not
purchasing it because library just made
a presentation so we are one of the
schools using error system heavily so if
you were to use Harvard Business
publishing LTI that would mean our
students would go to course files and
then Ford course reserves and then
Harvard cases so they would have to go
to three different places to get one
course material so we decided that
unless it integrates with course
resources or files we are not going to
use Harvard cases so we decided not to I
don't have an access to it right now
study net just another one I don't know
if you're familiar with study net study
net allows faculty members instructors
to create their course packs it could be
a website it could be a file that they
all created creation or it could be a
case that is developed and you know
presented by any other business school
so I'll we also tested it
and we decided that you are not going to
go with it because just like with
harvard business cases this required our
students and faculty to go to yet
another plat here right now currently
they only go to files and course reserve
which is down there but if the word to
you study net then they would also have
to go to study net to get some of the
files so we are looking for a solution
that will allow us to put all the
resources in one place so our students
and faculty they don't have to go to
three four different places we haven't
found it yet but we are looking and
continue to look so currently being
tested so our last two tools that
currently being tested and piloted one
of them is critic it it was introduced
by CTL so after investigating it I
introduced to one of our faculty members
he has used it for his spring class and
he actually for critic it as I mentioned
before some tools are available within
assignment so critic it's available only
through assignments so if you decide to
use a tool that allows faculty
instructors to use this tool so we have
to use critic it through assignments so
when they create an assignment and they
select external tool and students if
then need to do use it they go through
the assignments and critique it is
online critiquing tool that allows
instructors to or users I should say
because students can also upload files
they can upload their images or their
videos and people can or even like word
files and people can give comments on
them they can record videos and they can
provide comments on them
I'm going to do this fast but you know
you can ask me more because we have like
a couple of minutes left so currently I
we are also testing variscite i
mentioned our issues we turn it in so we
are investigating another online
plagiarism tool called variscite and
trying to see if it works better within
canvas so we are currently testing it so
we've been doing some tests and if we
decide okay this is better then i'm
going to ask a faculty member to pilot
it next for next fall and then we will
be able to decide after the pilot if
you're going to go with the tool or not
so again it's via assignments i external
tool select very very size so students
and they're uploading their files
you know assignment files they go within
canvas but they're actually uploading in
very site and faculty can access also
from canvas
finally coming soon so this is the tool
that we tested and they piloted we
didn't pilot within canvas but we
piloted outside and we decided to you
know go with it it's called mob lab it's
an online gaming for economics and
business cases so we are going to start
using it next fall and just like I
mentioned before mob lab is available
through assignments or modules so a
person would you presented about module
so we can put mob lab games and
activities under each module it allows
us to do that so as you can see first we
activate it so that's one thing some of
the internal external tools require
activation so we require students to
click their first to activate their
account and then they access through som
account and now their account is
activated in mob lab they can start
using it's obvious we can start weekly
modules and AdMob lab games for them to
access it
and thank you any questions yes so some
of them like the syllabus that we
developed and roster we developed but
mob lab very site Turnitin it's
developed by the company so I need to
have a final tool to my students to last
and the scheduler in canvas doesn't work
for what I need to do so I'm learning
how to do it in a platform a database
platform for our table it has an API but
the students will have access to I don't
have access to the roster and their
schedule and so forth so they have to
get an account of a separate separate
platform and so forth so it'd be great
if I could get the roster information
and so forth before but you know the air
table tool again with the canvas API so
have you that you need to contact Pilar
and her team I think you know we we
worked with them to create our own tools
for som but you have to check with them
so all the databases that we use for the
after came from som databases it works
yes and there's also some canvas groups
that they do they do share their
resources and developments on github
so you may find something like that
already developed and you just modify it
to your own purposes the rocker which
our developers are pulling information
that always within accurate to banner
and so in a people tool and then I know
the Robster portal that we use now that
it was calling different students so
yeah it's tricky but it's all for them
okay one other comment there's a website
edge you apt Center that list over 200
externally develop tools for various
things that are already plug-and-play
for campus that's not to say that you
can just immediately plug it in we have
some protocols for actually checking to
make sure that any data shared with an
external vendor it secure because of
profile and that sort of thing but we
might very well find an application that
does what you're looking for on the edge
web center and then you can contact the
campus group and say hey I would really
like to look into plugging this into my
phone and it's asking some questions
okay thank you
[Music]
you